course my good friend andy richter's
here hi andy hi conan how are you
i'm doing pretty well i'm glad to see uh
this makes a big difference you know we
we we took a page from major league
sports
and we we got uh our fans to send in
cardboard cutouts
uh we got so many and thousands and
thousands of people
sent in pictures we printed them out and
we put them here
to give us a packed audience yeah
gotta tell you maybe it's cause it's a
monday
they seem a little low energy right now
yeah it's yeah they're not
they don't have the same pep same uh
two-dimensional pep that they did last
week
yeah no they seem a little flat now
normally we have an audience
warm-up and i think they could use one
right now i think
maybe andy you could help me whip this
crowd
into a frenzy any thoughts sure sure i i
actually have just the thing if you if
you don't mind
yeah not at all andy richter now is
going to warm up
our cardboard audience get him excited
what do you got there right who wants a
t-shirt
yeah oh man this thing's got some juice
yeah try one you go how about you comey
oh yeah yeah what about one of you kevin
hart
oh sorry lady i was trying for kevin
hart
oh hey look you hit one kevin hart and
you knocked down
three of them that's the way it goes hey
you know what uh get one of these guys
who's being a wise ass find someone
who's being kind of a wise ass
let's see oh my gosh this guy right here
yeah hey why no smile buddy
[Laughter]
they're picking up andy i can feel the
energy rising they're pretty happy now
right reverend
yeah i still want to try and get comey
good
no you've got to get comey he has to pay
for his yeah what about her emails now
bow yes there he goes
justice uh
donate how about this guy don't act like
i don't see you kevin hart
oh wait you actually st
you you stood him back up all right i
think they're pretty pumped now
nice job andy you know i am nice job
man man much fun as i've had in a while
well sorry kevin seriously sorry buddy
well that's how we repay fans that take
the time to send us their photos
we blast them in the face with a t-shirt
cannon
at close range they got t-shirts out of
the deal
that may look unfriendly but i promise
you
every fan that was hit we're gonna send
them a photograph
of the t-shirt and then they can have it
made into a cardboard cutout cut out a
t-shirt